et nous sommes ce soir avec virginie
martin politologue professeur à laquelle
business school bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france a beau
côté thierry amouroux porte-parole
syndicats infirmiers snpi merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france et pour nous
livrer aussi son témoignage nous
rejoindre à tout à l'heure marcel
bénézet il est président des cafés bars
brasseries syndicats gn it here i am où
je me tourne vers vous pour commencer
nous bonsoir tiré à meaux
alors on va commencer avec vous thierry
type marcel bénézet pardon si un an ou
alors bien voilà vous m'entendez alors
une des mesures annoncées ce soir c'est
la fermeture des bars fermés à 22h donc
dans les zones d'alert fermeture totale
des bars et des restaurants à partir de
samedi est ce que vous comprenez cette
décision bien que vous dire le virus
devient tout d'un seul coup plus
virulents 22h59 c'est voilà nous ce que
l'on attend du du gouvernement c'est
qu'il soit beaucoup plus clair dans ses
consignes alors que là c'est difficile
d'avoir l'accord de la population sur
des des consignes qui semble un peu
curieuse donc du coup à 21h50 9 les
champs de se précipiter dans les
transports en commun bondés mais ça
n'est pas un souci ça juste justement
virginie martin est ce que vous y voyez
un paradoxe
thierry amouroux le soulignait on peut
voir aux
de pointe beaucoup de monde dans les
transports en commun et puis ce soit on
a cette annonce de nouvelles mesures
basées sur beaucoup moins d'interactions
sociales finalement comment vous le
comprenez c'est à dire si c'est
difficile à comprendre parce que là le
gouvernement doit impérativement faute
d'avoir correctement anticipée après le
confinement donc à avoir correctement
géré le déconfinement ceux des
confinement a été extrêmement mal géré
on le voit aujourd'hui de toute façon on
en a la preuve donc il devrait dans une
communication de crise
rassurante et enfin de cette
communication de crise elle se veut
tellement rassurante tellement peu clair
qu'elles ont fini par être pas clair
vous voyez pour pas créer l'anxiété ou
le côté anxiogène finalement on met
plein de mots des graphiques des cartes
des sur carte des roses carte rouge
foncé en rouge clair rouge écarlate ans
ça devient absolument insupportable les
messages ne sont pas claires et donc le
manque de clarté va encore créer de la
confusion parce que le gouvernement a
besoin d'un choc de confiance pour que
la population adhère à ces mesures
nous avons tous plus ou moins adhérer au
confinement
vous comprenez bien que là ça si je peux
dire son crédit de son crédit d'adhésion
il est à zéro aujourd'hui pour le
gouvernement
donc il fallait aussi créé un choc de
confiance plus grand et là on sent tout
de suite que le messager déliter il est
des lits délétère aussi il est reçu de
manière assez critique tout de suite en
fait quand on regarde les réseaux
sociaux ça s'enflamme tout de suite
il vient pression est ce qu'on n'a pas
aussi un peu l'impression de revenir un
peu en arrière au moment de ces points
quotidiens pendant le confinement
justement qu'ils étaient eux aussi
considérés comme anxiogène finalement
oui bien sûr mais pas parce qu'aussi
aura il ya eu un confinement puis après
un dea confinement il fallait gérer
après ça il fallait gérer petits pas à
petit pas qu'est ce qui s'est passé on a
ouvert les vannes complètement monsieur
déconfinement est devenu pour les mines
ce sera une semaine dix jours et après
ça a été l'été où on a décidé que
c'était l'été de tous les dangers
forcément pour septembre bah oui hall
alors qu'on aurait dû faire beaucoup
plus attention que le gouvernement
révèle beaucoup plus anticipateur
beaucoup un meilleur gestionnaire si je
puis dire en bon père en bonne mère de
famille nous avons mis un gouvernement
démissionnaire pendant deux mois et un
président de république aussi forcément
que maintenant on rattrape
on est toujours en train de courir après
le virus après cette histoire
la politique c'est anticiper c'est pas
possible autrement
alors on va retrouver marcel bénézet
voilà il nous a rejoint président des
cafés bars brasseries syndicat gmb alors
peut-être votre réaction à sur cette
annonce du soir fermeture totale des
bars et restaurants à marseille dans les
zones d' alerte rouge écarlate si on
peut les appeler comme ça quelle est
votre réaction
vous la comprenez action ma réaction est
un peu de colère parce que nous reste
nous avons un protocole sanitaire que
nous respectons scrupuleusement donc
aujourd'hui fermé nos établissements
nous à 22h je pense que c'est une grave
erreur parce que nous allons avoir tout
ce public qui vont se retrouver dans des
jardins dans l'espoir dans les espaces
publics avec des boissons alcoolisées
sans contrôle je pense que l'erreur fait
fausse route l'état fait fausse route
je pense qu'il doit nous laisser gérer
une situation que nous connaissons
parce que nous avons quand même
l'habitude de gérer ce genre de ce genre
de 2,2 de nous nos deux établissements
donc nous avons l'habitude dont il faut
nous laisser travailler parce que le
fermer nos établissements maintenant ça
veut dire que le service du soir est
condamné c'est jeter nous c'est jeter
nos établissements dans un gouffre où
nous sommes déjà aujourd'hui je suis
très inquiet pour la profession nous
sommes déjà à genoux et la cc nous jeter
dans le gouffre et on s'en remettra pas
donc et nous gérons la situation
je pense que c'est pas rendre service à
la jeunesse que de les laisser partir
après 22 heures sans aucun établissement
ouvert ils vont consommer dans des
conditions insupportables et se mettre
en danger ce sont là dans des
appartements dans des lieux confinés
chez eux dans des petits studios parce
que ce sont les étudiants qui arrivent à
paris et je pense qu'il vaut mieux
qu'ils soient chez nous que
un des espaces privés amouroux vous êtes
soignants vous êtes le porte parole
syndical je le rappelle infirmiers sn
pays olivier ferrand l'a rappelé ce soir
la tension qu'il y a à l'heure actuelle
dans les hôpitaux une tension qui
revient est ce que vous comprenez ce que
vient de nous dire marcel bénézet rose
en nous on maîtrise on sait faire
finalement c'est mieux que de laisser
les jeunes traîner un peu partout dans
la rue et peut-être avec plus de
contamination quel est votre regard sur
ce que vient de dire marcel bénézet oui
tout à fait c'est ce que l'on ressent
aussi nous on préférerait que le l'état
se concentre sur donner les moyens aux
hôpitaux de pouvoir répondre à la
deuxième vague de donner les moyens aux
soignants d'avoir le matériel de
protection nécessaires alors qu'on est
en tension depuis début juin sur les
gants médicaux sur les sur blue sur les
masques sens du matériel il vous manque
encore du matériel aujourd'hui c'est ce
que vous nous dites on est en tension
alors qu' il y avait une faible activité
affectueuse comprenez que des vous êtes
en pic infectieux le la consommation
multipliée par dix donc en quelques
jours on va se retrouver de nouveau avec
des sacs poubelles sur le dos tout ça
parce que le gouvernement est incapable
de faire ce qu'on attend de l'usi qu'on
lui demande depuis le mois de mars à
savoir de réquisitionner des usines
textiles pour qu'au lieu de fabriquer de
la lingerie elle fasse les les gants les
masques
et tout le matériel dont nous avons
besoin parce que là on est toujours dans
la pensée magique
je lancerai une commande et puis la
chine fournira ah bah non parce que vous
avez tous les pays du monde qui commande
en même temps le même type de matériel
donc il ya de la tension
donc il faut fabriquer sur le sol
français
le matériel nécessaire aux soignants
français pour répondre aux besoins de
santé des français
virginie martin c'est ce manque
d'anticipation la dont vous parliez tout
à l'heure dont il s'agit on aurait pu
anticiper justement la fabrication en
france du matériel nécessaire en cas
d'une éventuelle seconde vague et bien
sûr c'est c'est tellement évident je le
répète
gouverner c'est avant tout anticiper
c'est gérer ces situations de crise
c'est y être prêts y être préparé alors
est ce que le gouvernement par
finalement line expérimentation
l'inexpérience excusez-moi de ses
ministres du président de la république
lui-même finalement sont confrontés à
quelque chose qui les dépasse c'est ça
aussi qui crée le côté anxiogène de
cette affaire parce que comme et ça a
été dit précédemment
depuis le mois de mars vous savez on
pouvait peut-être pardonner certains ont
pardonné au gouvernement à l'exécutif
ainsi bendaya agnès buzyn emmanuel
macron lui-même au mois de mars quand
ils ont dit excusez nous on nous étions
pas prêt mais au moins septembre fin
septembre qik encore le faire quoi que
nous ne sommes pas prêts à part parce
que nous n'avons rien fait c'est quand
même très étonnant voyez il ya aussi un
peu de bon sens à faire et ce soir quand
on entend les révérends on aurait
peut-être aimé alors pas forcément sur
toutes les mesures moi je ne suis pas là
pour juger les mesures je ne suis pas ni
médecin ni n'y aura ni épidémiologie des
violeurs et tout ce genre de choses
évidemment
mais mais juste le bon sens le bon sens
aurait peut-être aimé entend toujours
deux mesures il ya quinze jours trois
semaines
vous savez moi je suis en direct de
marseille pour qui a été à marseille au
mois d'août et de juillet
je vous assure que ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui était une évidence une
évidence parce que la distanciation
social rien été respectée comment vous
l'expliquez bah oui parce que tout le
monde s'est il réjoui des 30% de plus de
touristes à marseille et puis voilà et
puis de la bonne activité de la vie de
la belle attractivité ça c'est fabuleux
mais si vous aviez vu enfin c'était
véritablement les modes sur les plages d
d d d d des centaines et des centaines
et des centaines de personnes sur des
mètres carrés de plage quand même tout
petit c'est quand même pas les grandes
plages du de biarritz à vars n 1 je vous
le rappelle est il s'était vraiment
accessible oui tendue sur sur le vieux
port il y avait aussi des des masses et
des masses de population de touristes de
locaux etc
c'était écrit si je puis dire il
suffisait de regarder
donc voilà alors l'anticipation c'est
dommageable c'est vraiment dommageable
parce que on est obligé de faire
confiance au gouvernement parce que
c'est lui qui a les rênes c'est lui qui
a les mesures les préfets et les maires
et on al'impression un petit peu mais ça
depuis mars à que finalement ce qu'ils
sont les meilleurs conseillers de ces
nous mène voilà c'est tiré amour vous
payer quoi aujourd'hui avec la fermeture
des bars et des restaurants on le
rappelle à marseille notamment la
fermeture à 22 heures dans les zones les
zones d' alerte renforcée
vous payez quoi aujourd'hui c'est
finalement l'un discipline des français
pendant les vacances
ou alors c'est un manque d'écouté de
votre part vous n'avez pas été assez
écoutés par le gouvernement pour dire
oui nous on sait faire on peut
accueillir qu'est ce qui s'est passé
bien disons qu'il ya eu une telle
incohérence dans le discours du
gouvernement ou au départ banon les
masses ça servait à rien
au départ les tests non ça servait à
rien que finalement il ya une méfiance
qui déplaçait qui s'est installée et que
du coup les gens perdent le bon sens
c'est à dire que ça fait un siècle qu'on
sait que bâle en cas d'épidémie lady un
virus respiratoires faut mettre hamas
est bien là avec le cafouillis du
ministre au départ il ya des gens qui
doutent lépi après c'est du simple bon
sens quand vous êtes dans un espace clos
bah oui le masque il est indispensable
il faut aérer vos appartements il faut
aérer les bureaux il faut aérer tout ce
qu'on peut pour réduire la concentration
de virus et e bay le fait que deux
personnes est un masque le risque de
transmission est d'autant plus limité
voilà donc respecter les mesures
barrières c'est ça qui peut protéger
tout le monde parce que c'est une
maladie qui ne n'affecte pas uniquement
les personnes âgées même si ce sont les
les plus frappés il faut bien comprendre
que ben est où tous ces jeunes qui ont
beaucoup et échanger là en septembre ils
ont retrouvé leurs collègues plus âgés
ils ont retrouvé leurs parents leurs
grands parents
et c'est pour ça que ben il ya
aujourd'hui une tension dans les
hôpitaux où on voit que ça monte
progressivement alors c'est pas un
tsunami un com
comme au printemps mais on voit que ça
montre que c'est une pente et donc nous
on est inquiet parce que il faut bien
comprendre que dans le même temps
aujourd'hui nous avons moins de lits
qu'en janvier ce que le gouvernement a
continué sa politique de fermeture
d'établissement de fermetures de service
d'économie
de bout de chandelle sur sur la santé
même un hôpital aussi symbolique que le
chu de strasbourg
on a fermé 14 lits de réanimation sur ce
deux hôpitaux du chu de strasbourg au
mois de juin donc qu'on nous soignants
on apprend ça mais on tombe des nues
déjà nous avons cinq fois moins de lits
de réanimation que l'allemagne
l'allemagne avaient quatre fois moins de
morts parce qu'ils avaient ri il les
avait les lits de réanimation il avait
le personnel nous il ya 30%
d'infirmières de moins en france qu'en
allemagne pour 1000 habitants
par contre nous on a 35 %
d'administratifs de plus
donc voilà cette difficulté parce que on
parlait tout à l'heure du manque de
matériel de protection
mais on se retrouve avec les mêmes
problèmes qu'il ya six mois
c'est plus les masques chirurgicaux
cette fois ci c'est d'autres choses mais
nous on soignant on a payé un lourd
tribut sur la première vague
rien que sur ni l'établissement qui un
petit échantillonnage du nombre
d'hôpitaux et des bas dans france il y à
31 et soignants qui ont été contaminés
et victime du duc au vide
effectivement du coup marcel bénézet je
me tourne vers vous également je vous
pose finalement la même question vous
est ce que vous payez aussi pour
finalement ses vacances où les gens
peut-être au moins respecter les
distanciation social comme je disais
tout à l'heure est ce que vous avez
finalement là ce sentiment d'être des
victimes est ce que vous êtes
suffisamment écoutés par le gouvernement
est ce que vous avez pu élaborer un
dialogue avec eux justement pour éviter
ces fermetures et pour faire des
propositions mais nous les propositions
les en fait je suis je suis en tournée
je suis donc en plus je ne comprends pas
parce que je pensais pas qu on nous
ferme à 22 heures parce que ce n'était
pas à l'ordre du jour
je pense que c'est une grave erreur je
passe fermer nos établissements à 22h je
pense qu'on va mettre dans la rue tous
ces jeunes
et là ça va être graves parce qu'ils
vont sol comme je le répète la même
chose aujourd'hui laissez nous
travailler
nous avons travaillé en un protocole
sanitaire qui est contraint nous avons
travaillé je pense que ce serait de
fermer nos établissements à 22h07 une
erreur nous avons besoin de travailler
et nous sommes nous sommes dans un éco 1
et comme ici de parce qu'aujourd'hui la
situation est très grave dans
l'hôtellerie restauration
gilles martin effectivement c'est
l'économie en tout cas l'économie de la
restauration qui va encore trinquer
cette fois
hertz les coeurs de ville il ya toute
une économie bien entendu les des
économies et des écosystèmes
donc c'est très compliqué c'est pour ça
que je suis désolée de me répéter mais
on avait les moyens d'éviter ce qui est
en train de se passer
et donc c'est d'autant plus rageant
et donc il faut absolument que le
gouvernement s'il veut aussi qu'ils
aient moins de critiques par exemple les
discours anti masqué discours anti
vaccins les discours c'est pas grave
après tout et cetera il faut aussi
qu'ils recréent de la confiance
est-ce que c'est avec une conférence de
presse comme ce soir dans les vers en
qu'on recrée de la confiance non à 90%
non c'est évident donc on allait vers
une situation en aller vers le mur et
emmanuel macron faisait du scooter des
mers
enfin c'est quand même quelque chose de
très étrange
est-ce qu est-ce que nicolas sarkozy
faisait s'amuser comme ça pendant la
crise de 2008 financière est ce que
françois hollande s'amuser comme cela
pendant les crises terroriste qu'on a eu
en 2014 2015
moi je reste extrêmement surprise et de
mémoire de politologues j'en suis
absolument désolé je n'ai jamais vu
aussi peu de capacité à l'anticipation
et donc à la gouvernance d'un pays c'est
très important
c'est ce que disait monsieur il ya des
choses qu'on aurait pu prévenir qu qu'on
peut anticiper on peut aussi d'être dans
la co création la concertation la
coopération avec les acteurs et actrices
de terrain est sérieux c'est très
bizarre vu de manière calme et cette
mesure également de passer des
rassemblements de 5000 personnes
désormais à 1000
comment est-ce que vous la comprenez là
encore c'est efficace ou pas efficaces
je n'en sais rien à ce jour bien entendu
qu'il faut casser le plus possible et
chaîne de contamination ça je crois
qu'on a très bien compris et ça c'est
très important
donc forcément que maintenant
et ils y ont laissé filer juillet août
voire septembre on est quand même le vin
et quelques septembre de toute façon
voilà il ya eu trois mois quasiment rien
n'a été fait et donc forcément
qu'aujourd'hui on prend des mesures trop
forte trop drastiques
donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut aussi
peut-être tant pis qu'il faut faire il
faut faire un choc de mesures peut-être
pendant une semaine quinze jours pour
pouvoir revenir à quelque chose depuis
normal de plus rationnel et d'une
gouvernance qui est le meilleur est
beaucoup plus sensée et une gestion de
crise quelle cohérence mais sinon si
l'entreprise internationale gérer une
crise comme cela mais serait en faillite
dans la seconde
ça c'est plus possible aujourd'hui tirer
amoureux en tant que soignant vous êtes
rassurés quand même parcelle ces mesures
pour éviter la propagation
je parlais à l'instant justement de
cette mesure de passer de 5000 personnes
à 1000 personnes lors des rassemblements
ç'a un impact vous êtes quand même
rassuré non c'est un impact pour réduire
les manifestations c'est tout vous savez
il nous le gluher nous en tant que
soignant on a eu trois hommes trois
mesures iman qui viennent de s'enchaîner
les unes après les autres
la première c'est le décret sur la
reconnaissance ou non s'il vous pla
thierry amouroux parce qu'il nous reste
quelques secondes en quelques mans et
puis marcel bénézet nous dira le mot de
la fin on vous écoute
oui on vient de dire que la
reconnaissance d'espagne en maladie
professionnelle
ce sera réservé aux soignants décédés ou
ni sous assistance respiratoire
première chose deuxièmement un décret
pour licencier et le personnel
hospitalier et troisièmement au chu de
nice
on vient d'annoncer hausse régnante que
vous avez une pcr positive vous êtes
infectés mais vous continuez à soigner
les plus fun les patients vous ne prenez
pas d'arrêt parce que toute façon ils
sont affectés donc c'est pas grave de
l'airé infectés donc voilà trois mesures
qui viennent d'être prises et qui vous
disent le mépris envers les soignants et
après
voilà vous comprenez que les soignants
sont que l'air sont maltraitant les
paroles alors à côté de ça à réduire
c'est entendu c'est entendu
effectivement tirer amoureux c'est bien
entendu peut-être marcel bénézet en
quelques secondes le mot de la fin
oui moi je pense que ces mesures auront
un plein effet nous rendez vous dans
quelques jours ces mesures n'ont aucun
effet et non continuera ça n'aura aucun
effet je pose assuré il fallait nous
laisser travailler
on sait faire rendez vous dans quelques
jours il y aura pas de baisse de
contamination y en aura pas du tout la
beauté noter une erreur de choix et
c'est comme ça la date est notée
rendez-vous dans quinze jours en tout
cas merci à tous les trois d'avoir
accepté notre invitation virginie martin
politologue professeur laquelle je vis
des school thierry amouroux porte parole
le syndicat infirmier sm pays
merci à vous merci à vous également
marcel bénézet président des cafés bars
brasseries syndicats jeanny